vivimos en una democracia el perú de
nuestra patria y yo como todos ustedes
quiero lo mejor para nuestro país
hace unos días juramente como presidente
de la república para liderar un gobierno
de transición por mandato constitucional
ante la vacancia presidencial producida
hace unos días correspondía al
presidente del congreso de república a
asumir el más alto cargo de nuestro país
y lo hice con responsabilidad humildad y
honor fue un reto que acepté y no busqué
desde antes que se produjera la vacancia
hubo voces que pretendieron confundir al
país diciendo que se estaba buscando
sacar al presidente de la república para
postergar las elecciones e intentar que
un grupo con mi participación busque
perpetuarse del poder
soy demócrata respeto a las
instituciones y las leyes este es un
gobierno de transición y nuestro primer
deber político es garantizar las
elecciones transparentes y limpias nada
ni nadie puede impedir que las
elecciones generales se realicen el 11
de abril del año 2021 estamos en un
proceso electoral en marcha el pueblo
tiene el deber de elegir
democráticamente a sus autoridades
fue mi compromiso desde que asumió este
cargo constitucional
que nunca estuvo en duda
sé que muchos peruanos y peruanas están
hastiados de los vaivenes de la clase
política pero son ciudadanos
los únicos que pueden elegir libremente
a sus autoridades cada peruano o peruana
que participe
en las marchas o no tiene el poder del
voto en las urnas y ese voto está
garantizado
es tiempo de paz y de unidad
soy padre de familia
tengo tres hijas mi madre mis hermanos
mi esposo
en mi corazón late los ideales de mi
juventud que me impulsaron a ingresar a
la política creo que el perú si puede
salir adelante con honestidad educación
trabajo y solidaridad
creo en la lucha frontal contra la
corrupción
los corruptos no pueden de ninguna
manera representarnos ningún presidente
detener acusaciones de haber recibido
coimas creo que el poder es para servir
a los demás y no para servir a intereses
subalternos
la legítima protesta donde hay muchas
voces jóvenes tienen también
lamentablemente a grupos interesados en
producir caos y violencia
ninguna salida a esta crisis debe
realizarse fuera del marco legal y
constitucional todos debemos defender la
democracia
yo no soy un político de casualidad que
sólo aparece para ser un candidato a las
elecciones he tenido la oportunidad de
estar tres veces en el parlamento
nacional
y se lo está bien es que tengo que
cumplir
sé que algunos piden mi renuncia soy un
hombre de estado y soy consciente que no
puede haber un vacío un vacío de poder
en ese sentido he recibido las cartas
poniendo su cargo a disposición de todos
los ministros debo anunciar que los
ministros continuarán en sus cargos
hasta que la incertidumbre del momento
actual en que vivimos se pueda resolver
de ninguna manera habrá un vacío de
poder
a sí mismo
en este momento donde el país atraviesa
una de las más grandes crisis políticas
quiero hacer reconocimiento a todo el
país que presentó mi renuncia
irrevocable del cargo de presidente de
la república
e invocó a la paz y la unidad de todos
los peruanos
mi compromiso es como perú
y haré el mayor de mis esfuerzos para
poder garantizar la sucesión
constitucional que el congreso determine
el perú merece seguir adelante
quiero terminar agradeciéndole a todos
los miembros del gabinete que me han
acompañado en este reto que el perú nos
ha puesto y espero lo mejor para todos
los peruanos muchas gracias